So in this next section,
we're gonna talk about tracking solutions
and the creation of a rigid body objects.
This is required for tracking.
So as we go through here,
we are gonna talk specifically
about the OptiTrack Motive System,
but I'm not gonna demonstrate this
because there is plenty of documentation
on the respective websites for the actual vendor
that provides these tracking solutions.
So I just wanna point out here
that there are active and passive options
that are available out here.
So the 209 group, we use the mine at the latte stage.
It is an active camera tracking unit.
You can just visit the 209 group to purchase this,
although there's probably going to be some of a wait time
for this particular tool set.
There is also the option of just using passive markers
and creating your own Sputnik,
much like the Epic Games custom Sputnik
that was created by Kevin Cushing.
This system is passive,
so it doesn't have the battery requirements,
but again, because it's not an active system,
it's not quite as accurate
or can be not as accurate as the active tracking system.
However, because it doesn't require batteries
and it doesn't require any kind of power supply,
it can last much longer than our active systems.
Now, we also have the option of using an OptiTrack Puck
as a tracking unit or the VIVE tracker.
Vicon also has several options as well
for passive marker systems.
If you're using a custom Sputnik,
that would work in both the Vicon
and the OptiTrack systems
because it is a passive system
and markers are typically universal.
So the VIVE tracker, the VIVE Mars tracking system,
those will also work that as well.
Now, any tracked object and CG model
can be created to suit your needs.
The process includes adding calibration points
that are set up correctly on the CG model
to match the tracked object
and that the Latte Stage and Lab use an OptiTrack Puck
for nodal point calibration.
The checkerboard is not required
So the checkerboard we created in the last class
is not necessary for nodal point calibration,
but it is required for your lens distortion mapping.
Now, the Latte Stage, as I mentioned,
does use the OptiTrack Motive system
and we will provide anyone
who is using the OptiTrack system
with the CG model that we created for the OptiTrack Puck.
It has a little bump,
so it's not exactly matching the OptiTrack Puck,
but that little bump is just the front of the Puck
versus the back of the Puck.
Now, as I go through here and look at my nodal point,
again, we are going to provide you
with the OBJ and FBX that you can use in here.
You can actually bring this into any system.
So if you have a tracked object in the Motive system
or in the Shogun system, you can use this in both.
It is just an FBX, it is just an OBJ.
You have these, this mesh was created in Autodesk Maya.
However, this is not gonna match
Vicon's tracking Puck or their active tracker.
That system is gonna look a little bit different
than what you have here.
Now, the nodal point of a physical camera
is the point where light rays converge in a lens.
And in order to calculate the nodal offset
that will be applied to the cine camera,
a series of tracked objects need to be created
that match the physically tracked object
that is in use by the tracking solution,
such as OptiTrax Motive.
Now, again, we start with our CG model here.
This OptiPuck track object is what's going to go
into two different locations.
So the OBJ version is gonna go into OptiTrax Motive,
and that's what we're gonna use to create a rigid body.
And then the FBX version is gonna go into Unreal Engine.
And we'll talk about actually putting that together
in Unreal Engine.
However, the nodal object that we're going to be
creating for the tracked object in OptiTrax Motive,
we're not actually gonna go through.
Creating a tracked object is something that you can look up
on OptiTrax website and follow their documentation as well.
But we are going to briefly discuss this
by taking a look at the slides here,
which walks you through some steps inside Motive
to select your track markers from your puck itself,
create your tracked object, and then make adjustments.
Now, additionally, you are going to need to tweak
the position of the puck so it is lined up correctly
so that the alignment for the OBJ does match
as close as possible to the markers
that are streaming in here,
because we wanna be able to match and line up
the dimensions of the physical object in CG model
to our tracked object.
So that's it for creating your tracked objects.
Next, we're gonna talk about creating our tracked object
in Unreal Engine.
And again, we are using the OptiTrax Motive system
and the two objects that we have here available to us.